شكرا للزميل طالب كنعان اهلا بكم مشاهدينا
الى هذه التغطيه المستمره للتطورات في
السودان بعد المنعرج الخطير الذي دخلته
البلاد منذ ثمانيه ايام فقد تحدث رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني والقائد العام
للجيش الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
للعربيه منذ قليل مؤكدا مشاطرته المجتمع
الدولي القلق تجاه الرعايا الاجانب في
السودان اكد ان الوضع في تدهور مستمر وحمل
قوات الدعم السريع مسؤوليه التعدي على
البعثات الدبلوماسيه دون مراعاه للقانون
الدولي البرهان كشف للعربيه ايضا عن ان كل
مطارات البلاد تحت سيطره الجيش ما عدا
مطري الخرطوم ونياله حتى الان البرهان
اتهم الدعم السريعه بالانتشار في الاحياء
السكنيه واستخدام المدنيين كدروع بشريه
قائد الجيش اكد انه سيدافع عن مقر القياده
العامه للجيش والا وانه لن يغادره الا
على نعش وعن موقع قائد قوات الدعم السريع
الجنرال حميتي قال البرهان ان حتى قوات
الجنرالو لا تعرف
[موسيقى]
انا موجود في هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومبارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرفي من اخرج الا محمولا على
نعش ستوري وادافع عن الدوله السودانيه ولا
ادافع عن شخص ولا ادافع عن جهه ولا دافع
عن كيان انا ادافع عن السودان ادافع عن
وحدته مدافع عن بقاء مدافع عن السودانيين
جميعا انا موجود صحيح المنزل تم تسلل نصوص
اظن ذلك نصوص داخل المنزل من بعض المنزل
هو في طرف ليس داخل القياده
وعاصم فيه فتاه
لديه اي
علاقه سابق ولا جميع يعلم ذلك نحن قوات
مسلحه نعمل بمثليه واحترافيه وواجبنا
حمايه السودان حتى
معظم من هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه حق اريد بها باطل او كلمه
باطل فيها
[موسيقى]
تجري الدول الاعضاء الخمسه في مجلس الامن
مناقشات حول احتمال عقد جلسه مفتوحه بمجلس
الامن الدولي عن السودان الاحد او الاثنين
وقالت بعثه السودان في الامم المتحده
للعربيه ان الجلسه المقرره سيتم عقدها وفق
قواعد الاجراءات الدوليه ولا يمكن منع عقد
الاجتماع طالما تم طلب ذلك من اعضاء
المجلس اضافت بعثه السودان انه يجب ان
تكون نتائج الاجتماع مرضيه وليست مجرده
ظهور اعلامي
اتم نائب رئيس الاركان السودانيه الفريق
عبد المحمود العجمي قوات الدعم السريع
بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه قبل ان تبدا وشدد
العجم على ان قواته تلاحق الدعم السريع
وتطردها من ولايات السودان
بتاع الناس اللي في المستشفيات والاطفال
والرضع قال ممكن تكون في هدنه بغرض ايساني
فقط فيما تبقى من يوم يومين ان شاء الله
نعلن الخرطوم دي
ما في ولايه من ولايه السودان فيها حاجه
اسمها دعم سريع
الجيوب المتبقيه هنا خلال يوم يومين
الموضوع ده خلاص انتهى
العربيه ان سته اشخاص من عائله واحده
قتلوا واصيب شخص اخر بجروح خطيره بعد سقوط
قذائف مدفعيه على حي المنصوره السكني في
ام درمان
ضربت
في شظايا
اتضربت في الميدان ضربت وطلبت
وا
ضربت الجماعه
وانا ما مرقت في الشارع
الاولى من السعوديين ورعايه بعض الدول
القادمين بحرا من السودان وذلك عبر خمس
سفن من بينها سفينه تموين وذلك ضمن عمليه
اجلاء قامت بها السعوديه لمئه و 158 شخصا
من مواطنيها ورعايا عشري دول اخرى على
خلفيه الازمه التي تشهدها السودان منذ
ايام
وينضم الينا السفير السعوديه لدى السودان
علي بن حسن بن جعفر سعاده السفير مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه
اسالك بدايه عن الترتيبات لاجلاء
المواطنين والرعايه من السودان الى
السعوديه كيف تمت
اهلا وسهلا وكل عام وانتم طيبين
كل عام وانتم طيبين
الانفاذ لتوجيهات سيدي ومولاي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان عبد العزيز
يحفظه الله
والسيد
صاحب سمو الملكي ولي العهد مجلس الوزراء
ومتابعه دقيقه من سيدي صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير خالد بن سلمان
وزير الدفاع ورئيس اللجنه العليا التي
شكلت باجلاء المواطن السعوديين وغيرهم من
[موسيقى]
الاجانب وكذلك دقيقه من سمو وزير الخارجيه
وموظفي وزاره الخارجيه
عملنا على اخراج
كل المواطنين السعوديين وغيرهم من الرعايه
دول الخليج والعجائب الذين اتصلوا بينا
خرجنا في ثلاث مواكب من الخرطوم
الى منطقه انتقاء في شرق الليل والحمد لله
استطعنا الرغم الظروف
الانتقاليه ان تخرج هذه المواكب الثلاثه
الى
ثم بعد ذلك انطلقنا الى
ولايه الجزيره ثم ولايه الخضاره مولايه
كسلا ثم ولايه البحر الاحمر حيث مدينه
بورسودات كل من خلال مسيره الموقف الذي
تتكون من 32 سياره كان كان ترافقنا حمايات
امنيه من اولاد الولايات التي مرينا بها
الى
بفضل من الله سبحانه وانا اطمن الجميع ان
هذه الاجراءات اتخذ على مستوى وكل
التي تم اجناهم في صحه وسلامه والحمد لله
تفضل
من امن خروجكم من هذه
من هذه الولايات هل الجيش السوداني كان
شريكا وراعيا لتامين وصولكم الى يعني
نحن كنا
نتواصل مع الكل
لتامين سلامه الموقف والحمد لله كان
في يعني تجاوب
بمطالبتنا ولم يعترضنا اي اي انسان
في ان كان عسكري او اشكال للتمويل التمويل
بالوقود كلها كانت ميسره ومسهله الى وصلنا
للكلام في مدينه بورسودان وحيث كانت
السعوديه قد وصلت مجاهزه واتمنى عمليه
الانجلاب نسبه سهوله هل تم اجلاء اعضاء
السفاره بالكامل
كلهم بالكامل
خليه من السفاره يبقى في بورسودان
لتنفيذ التوجيهات الكريمه
[موسيقى]
العديد من مواطنين الذين ابدوا رغبتهم في
الاجراء طيب كذلك ايضا سؤال عن طاقم
الخطوط السعوديه الذي كان موجود
باستضافتكم سعاده السفير في السودان
مع بدايه تضررت الطائره السعوديه
واستطعنا بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى يخرجهم
من دائره الاشتباكات الواقعه في المطار
الى مبنى السفاره وقضوا معنا خمسه ايام في
السفاره
في امان حتى
الان وصلوا الى مدير جده
بيسوى كلامه احد الطائره او احد من
المسافرين بعد هذا الاعتداء ابدا
تضرر احد من
هل هناك يعني مستقبلنا او خلال الايام
القادمه تامين لخروج بعض رعايه الدول يعني
مثل الرعايه الذين خرجوا معكم يعني في هذه
اليوم اليوم
ونحن من هنا تواصلنا مع الجهات التي
استطاعت ياسر موكب
خرج من رعايه الاردنيين
والحمد لله خرج من منطقه
السودان منطقه الخرطوم وهم نتابعهم في
تاريخهم ان شاء الله يوصولهم الليله كذلك
الموريتانيين نفس الحكايه الليبيين
اخرجناهم الله سبحانه وتعالى ثم
بتوجيهات جديده من القياده يحفظهم هل هناك
سعوديون اتفضلوا البقاء في السودان
لا يوجد
اتصل بنا عدد من السعوديين موجودين في بعض
الولايات
وهم في طريقهم الينا ان شاء الله وصولهم
اليوم
هناك اعداد مقدره لمن بقي من السعوديين في
السودان الى الان
اعداد قليله يعني في مدينه مروي في مدينه
مدني اربعه اشخاص في مدينه
هذولي يعني هذه المدن يعني ليست داخله في
قرن عمليات وبالتالي وامنا لهم السفر وكل
ما يلزم الى وصولهم ان شاء الله الليله
مستقبلهم في
في
ساعات السفير يعني مع اجلاء المواطنين
السعوديين الموجودين في السودان اعلنتم
بان هناك رعايه من دول اخرى يعني خرجوا من
بورت سودان الى جده في هذه السفن خمس سفر
نتحدث الان هل هناك تقديرات لاعدادهم اولا
من اي الدول وعلى اي اساس يعني تم
اختيارهم للخروج معكم
لا يوجد حقيقه
لكن قبل خروج الهواء لهم الرغبه في معانا
بعضهم تجاوب معنا سريع فاغلب
الذين تجاوب معاهم السفير ورعايه السفاره
القطريه السفير العماني
بالاعمال الكويتي والرعايه الكويتيين
وعدد من الجنسيات الاجنبيه عندنا من بنك
الدولي مركز البنك الدولي وزوجها عندنا
مسؤوله من كندا
نباتيه خرجوا معنا والحمد لله الان هم في
جده بالنسبه للسفاره السعوديه هل لا زالت
اعمالها قائمه الان في الخرطوم ام علقتم
العمل في السفاره بسبب الاحداث الجارحه
حاليا
طيب انتم
نقلتها الى اين نقلت اعمالها الى اين الى
بورسودان
وانت ستستمر بالعمل من بورتسودان اكيد نعم
انا سلم من زملائنا
الدبلوماسيين السعوديه شكرا جزيلا لك
سفير وانت طيب السفير السعودي لدى السودان
علي بن حسن بن جعفر
رصدت كاميرا العربيه ازمه الخبز التي بدات
في الظهور في الخرطوم حيث ظهرت الطوابير
امام الافران نتابع
وتنضم الي هنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في الخرطوم لينا يعقوب لينا مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه دعيني
ابدا من هذه الازمه التي شاهدناها قبل
قليل
هي عباره عن واحده من حلقات هذه الازمات
الموجوده في السودان
الى اي مدى هناك ازمه غذائيه في السودان
يعني بعد هذه الاحداث التي طلبت سوداء
مؤخرا
نعم هناك ازمه في الحقيقه ليست في كل
الولايات السودانيه او كل المناطق هناك
ولايات سودانيه مستقره لم تشهد اشتباكات
فيها سيطره للجيش السوداني لكن الاشتباكات
اكثر في الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم مناطق في
بحري وام درمان كانت قبل يومين ايضا في
مناطق ماهوله بالمحال التجاريه
والسوبر ماركتات وكذلك مطاعم تاثرت كلها
واليوم نشاهد كثير من الفيديوهات التي
اشارت بصوره واضحه الى تاثرهم بهذا
الاشتباك او بالنهو عمليات الاجرام الاخرى
هناك تاثر في الامداد الان لكثير من
المخابز نسبه لصعوبه الحركه ونسبه لقلق
المواطنين من التحرك خاصه في ظل انتشار
عربات للدعم السريع في بعض الاحياء
السكنيه او المواقع وكذلك في ظل القلق من
هذا القصف واطلاق النيران لذلك نجد ان
هناك تخوف من الامداد القمح امداد الدقيق
للمخابس طبعا امدادات القمح
يعني الشركات وامداد الدقيق الان يجب لي
المخابز ولكنه بصوره اقل نسبه لعدم عمل
هذه الشركات ونسبه ايضا لصعوبه الحركه
وكذلك نقص الوقود الذي بدا واضحا امس حيث
كانت هناك كثير من محطات الوقود تشهد
تكدسا للعربات وهناك طبعا محطات وقود دمرت
كذلك دمرت قصفت نعم طيب السؤال ايضا لا
يوجد هناك اي امداد من خارج الخرطوم الى
داخل الخرطوم اتحدث عن امداد بالوقود
امداد بالمواد الغذائيه ايضا من الولايات
المستقره على الاقل الى داخل الخرطوم ام
ان الاوضاع صعبه في الخرطوم وبالتالي لا
تفضل هذه الشركات الدخول الى الخرطوم اول
ارسال حتى ايضا شاحنات او قطره الى هناك
تم
استراتيجي فهناك مخزون احتياطي في كثير من
الولايات السودانيه لذلك الان حينما نتحدث
عن نقص نقص في الادويه نقص في الخبز نقص
الامداد المائي والكهربائي نتحدث اكثر
منطقه متضرره هي الخرطوم كما اشرت هناك
استقرار نسبي في الولايات السودانيه خاصه
التي لم تشهد اشتباكات وفيها سيطره للجيش
السوداني هناك ولايات دارفور شهدت
اشتباكات وكان هناك قتلى وتاثرت
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه لكن في
الخرطوم هناك صعوبه في الحركه هناك بعض
حتى الاعلاميين المتواجدين في ولايه
سودانيه الان يخشون من القدوم الى الخرطوم
لان الطريق ليس امن ولكن بدات الان هناك
اتصالات تتم بين المواطنين السودانيين
بينهم وبين ربما ايضا في بعض الاحيان مع
الجيش السوداني لضمان الطريقه الاكثر امنا
حتى يتمكنوا من الوصول هذه الان الشابه
تظهر في ايام الم وتنشط وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وبعض الصفحات لتحديد
الاماكن التي يمكن ان توفر مثلا خبز في في
مناطق معينه في بحري او في مناطق معينه في
الخرطوم او كذلك
التركيز ربما خلال هذه الايام هو على
الخرطوم مباشره لانها مسرح هذه الاشتباكات
لكن بالنسبه لولايات مثل دارفور مثلا امس
دارت اشتباكات القتلى اعتقد فاقو المئه ان
كان صحه هذه التقديرات يعني انا قراتها
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وبعض الصحف
السوداني ما الذي يدور في دارفور ومدى
ارتباطه بما يحدث في الخرطوم
هناك ارتباط لان هناك تواجد لقوات الدعم
السريع في ولايه دارفرونه نحن نعلم انها
ايضا كانت يعني مركز للدعم السريع قبل ان
ياتي الدعم السريع بمرور السنوات الماضيه
عبر دفعات والسنوات الى الخرطوم وتتمركز
هذه القوات هنا هناك فيديوهات عرضتها حتى
العربيه امس اشارت الى نهب في السوق في
نياله وكذلك في في بعض المدن في ولايات
دارفور هناك عمليات تمت لنهب السوق
ولاحراق السوق بطريقه متعمده تحدث الينا
احد الصحفيين انا اذكر انه ابو ذر وهو من
انيالا تحدث عن ان هناك استهداف يتم
عمليات نهب واجرام في السوق والمحال
التجاريه وكذلك المحلات لبيع الهواتف
وغيرها هذا يشير الى فوضى هناك صحيح ان
هناك اقتتال حدث وتحدث عنه الوالي قال في
بدء الاحصائيات انهم 24 ثم بعد ذلك زادوا
عن 50 ان تتحدث يعني حتى ان هناك بعض
المواقع تحدثت عن 100 قتيل نعم بالتالي
هناك تزايد لهذه الاحصائيات في ظل عدم
وجود امان وكانت هناك مناشده عبر الوالي
للاطراف المتصارعه بان تتوقف في اقتتالها
في ولايه دارفور باعتبارها انها ايضا هشه
بسهوله يمكن ان ينتشر
عمليات السلب والنهب في بعض المدن المتابع
العربي للمشهد السوداني يسال هذه الايام
عن عمليات الجرائم والسرقه والنهب التي
تتم فيها قوات الدعم السريع يقول احدهم
مثلا بان
حمدتي واحد من اثر
الاثرياء يعني في في قاره افريقيا
فبالتالي من المفترض ان وضع الافراد
وعناصر الدعم السريع ماليا يكون وضع جيد
بحكم ان قائد الدعم السريع هو حمتي فلماذا
الاتجاه لهذه العمليات السرق والنهب
وغيرها الماديه افضل من غيرهم يعني
والله يا نايف يعني هو سؤال ممكن صعب ولكن
يمكن ان اقول لك
لا يوجد توجيه من قائد الدعم السريع طبعا
لقواته بان يقوموا بهذه العمليات على
الاطلاق يعني لا يمكن ان يقول لهم
عمليات فرديه ام فيها توجيه او غير يبدو
انها يبدو ليست فيها توجيه ربما الاقتتال
نعم يعني بكلا الطرفين الجيش والدعم
السريع هناك توجيهات تاتيلي للاقتتال هذا
الاقتتال يروح ضحيته مدنيين ولكن حينما
نتحدث عن عمليات الاجرام فهي الان كما
تبدو بحسب شهود عيان انا اتحدث نقلا عن
شهود عيان احاول ان استوثق من هذا الامر
حتى حتى لا يتهم الدعم السريع بصوره كليه
بانه يقوم بهذه العمليات خاصه انه نفى ذلك
ولكن مقاطع الفيديو كثير من الناشطين
الصحفي نعم هم البرهان والجيش يتحدث عن
ذلك يعني من بدايه ايام الحرب الاولى ولكن
الان استيعاب الناس لهذه المساله باتت
تتضح كثير من مقاطع الفيديو كثير من
الامور التي تتم الان يعني يظهر فيها او
يتحدث سكان المنزل المتضرر بان هناك قوات
يعني نحن في البيت كنا نقول قوات ترزيه
الدعم السريع حتى نحن لسنا متاكدين انهم
دعم سريع ولكن بعد ذلك
بتكرار هذه المشاهد برؤيه السيارات برؤيه
الارقام بهذا الانتشار بهذا القصف تبين لي
بعض المواطنين ان هناك عمليات نهب تتم
وعمليات سرقه التتمه دعني اتحدث ايضا عن
امر اخر هو ليست كل هذه الجرائم الان يعني
تحدث في كل مدن الخرطوم او ان الدعم
السريع حينما يتواجد في اي منطقه يقوم
بهذه العمليات ولكن مثلا هذا تحليل تحليل
قاله احد الاشخاص بان الجيش مثلا يستخدم
بعض التكتيكات من بينها حصار الدعم السريع
في مواقع محدده حينما ينقص مثلا يضطر
هؤلاء الجنود الى الدخول الى منازل واخذ
الاكل او غيره فهذه
التكتيكات عفوا العسكريه قد تؤدي الى ظهور
يعني بعض الاساليب الغير حميده ولكن ان
تنتشر طبعا وان يقوم او ان تقوم قوات مثلا
بفتح السجون او ان تظهر في كثير من مقاطع
الفيديو انها تنهب مثلا محل تجاريه هو امر
يؤثر على صوره الدعم السريع بشكل عام وهو
الامر الذي كان قائد الدعم السريع يحاول
عبر السنوات الماضيه طبعا ان يحسن من هذه
الصوره خاصه ان هناك اذا كانت هناك اي قوه
بسيطه او قليله العدد ارتكبت اي جرم
العالم يتحدث عن الدعم السريع وهو الامر
الذي لم يكن يرضيه ولكن الان هذه الاشياء
الان يتضرر منها السكان وهم الذين يتحدثون
عنها وانا دائما اسال فقط عن شهود العيال
عن المصادر عن المعلومات نحن لا نتمنى
طبعا
في هذا الموضوع لنا ايضا السؤال عن مقابله
البرهان اليوم مع العربيه اوضح فيها
العديد طبعا من النقاط المهمه كيف
تابع الاعلام الصحافه ايضا في السودان هذه
المقابله وابرز تصريعات البرهان ايضا مما
رصدت يعني في خلال الساعه الماضيه يبدو ان
الصحافه في السودان تعاني تعثر الان لا
صحف تطبع بالمناسبه هناك بعض المواقع
القليله التي تعمل وهي ايضا تعمل في ظل
تذبذب للانترنت
وتذبذب في في خدمه الاتصالات وهناك ضغط
كبير على الشبكه فبالتالي ما قراته هو في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يعني بعض
التصريحات المنقوله على لسان واراء طبعا
مختلفه يعني حول حول عدم انتهاء الحرب او
عدم يعني يعني عدم تحديد ربما موعد معين
لانتهاء هذه المعارك كان اكثر سؤال مت
يعني بين السودانيين والخيار الاخر
المطروح لهم خاصه اننا كنا نتحدث خلال
الايام الماضيه عن عن ما كنت اسميه انا
على الصعيد الشخصي الشخصي سفر وتم الان
يعني اطلاق مصطلح نزوح باعتبارنا الامر
اصبح قسريا على السودانيين بمغادره
الخرطوم والذهاب الى الولايه السودانيه
ومن بعدها محاوله ربما يعني الذهاب الى
الخارج طبعا ليس كل الاسر لان الامكانيات
لا تتوفر جميعا لديهم ولكن لكثير من الاسر
الان هناك محاوله للابتعاد عن مكان
الاشتباك اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل كانت معي هنا في
الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
شكرا
اذا نشاهد هذا الفيديو مشاهدينا
للمتداول قوات الدعم السريع اذا تقول انها
تصدت لي هجوم من الجيش السوداني في شرق
النيل اذا قوات الدعم السريع تنشر صورا
تقول انها استولت على معسكر للجيش في شرق
النيل كما نشاهد في هذه
الصور
لقوات الدعم السريع التي استولت على معسكر
للجيش السوداني بالكامل نستمع لصوت
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المعسكر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الاستخبارات
الله اكبر
الان
الله اكبر الان
قال دباباتهم الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اندلع حريق ضخم في مطار الخرطوم الدولي
وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي يشهد فيها
المطار حرائق منذ الدلع مواجهات العسكريه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
قال قائد قوه الدعم السريع محمد حمدانو
انه بحث هاتفيا مع وزيره خارجيه فرنسا
التطورات في السودان واضافلو انه ابلغ
وزيره خارجيه فرنسا الالتزام بالهدنه
ووقفه اطلاق النار مشيرا الى انه يتم
العمل لتسهيل اجلاء جميع الدول لرعاياها
قائد قوات الدعم السريع قال ايضا انما تم
الاتفاق عليه سيكون له تاثير مباشر على
مجمل الاوضاع في البلاد
الان الجيش السوداني يقول في هذا الخبر
العاجل اسفل الشاشه وفي بيانه بان الحياه
بدات تعود تدريجيا الى العاصمه الخرطوم
وبقيه المدن اذا الجيش السوداني يقول بان
الحياه بدات تعود الى بدا تعود تدريجيا
الى العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وبقيه المدن يقول ايضا كذلك الجيش
السوداني في هذه
التصريحات او في هذا البيان
في اسفل الشاشه في الخبر العاجل بانه اخمد
تمرد قوات الدعم السريع وانه يتعامل معها
بالحسم اللازم اذا الجيش السوداني يقول
بانه اخمد تمرد قوات الدعم السريع وبانه
يتعامل معها بالحسم اللازم
واضاف ايضا بان قوات الدعم السريع تواصل
القصف المدفعي واعمال العنف اذا الجيش
السوداني يقول بان قوات الدعم السريع لا
زالت تواصل القصف المدفعي واع العنف ايضا
كذلك الجيش السوداني قال بانه اخمد تمرد
قوات الدعم السريع يتعامل معها بالحسم
اللازم وبان الحياه بدات تعود تدريجيا الى
العاصمه الخرطوم وبقيه المدن اضاف الجيش
السوداني في بينه ايضا انه من الصعب تحديد
مدى زمني لنهايه المواجهات ونسعى لانهائها
في اسرع وقت وهذا هو تاكيد لماذا ذكره
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني في تصريحاته للعربيه
اليوم بانه من الصعب ان يتم تحديد مدى
زمني لنهايه هذه
الحرب الجيش السوداني اكد عليها في هذا
البيان والجيش السوداني يقول بان هناك
محاولات يائسه من الدعم السريع لدفع
المزيد من قواتها الى داخل العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم التي ذكر هذا البيان
للجيش بان الحياه بدات تعود تدريجيا اليها
والى مدن اخرى ايضا كذلك وبانه من الصعب
تحديد وقت مده زمنيه لنهايه المواجهات
وبانه يسعى لانهائها في اسرع وقت يضيف
الجيش السوداني بانه اخمد تمرد قوات الدعم
السريع وبانه يتعامل معها بالحسم اللازم
وبان هناك محاولات يائسه من الدعم السريع
لدفع المزيد من قواتها الى العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم هذا ربما ابرز ما جاء
في بيان الجيش
السوداني والذي نتابعه اسفل الشاشه في
شريط الاخبار العاجله اذا مشاهدينا وفي
ذات الموضوع والملف السوداني تحدث موقع
اكسيوس الامريكي بحسب اربعه مصادر مطلعه
عن كيفيه تفجر الخلاف بين رئيس مجلس
السياده قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ومع
ظهور خلافاتهما للعلن اصبح من الصعب جدا
اقنعهما بالعوده الى المسار الديمقراطي
فكيلاهما دخل في معركه سلطه لن تتوقف
نارها الا باعلان احد الطرفين النصر حسب
الاتفاق يمرق بيمرق بلدنا يمرقنا لبر
الامان ما دارين مشاكل كان يعتلي المنابر
ويحض السودانيين على الالتزام بالاتفاق
وتاره اخرى يظهر وكانه الذراع الايمن
لرئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان انه نائبه قائد الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو المعروف بحميدتي
على الاطاحه بالرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
وبعد عامين طفت على السطح خلافاتهما وحولت
المشهد الى صراع سلطه
وبلادنا اصابها جرح بالغ صحيفه اكسيوس
الامريكيه وصفت القتال بينهما بانه اشبه
بمعركه غرور كبلت السودان في هاويه
الصراعات الدمويه ومعها كشفت كيف تفجرت
الاوضاع بينهما وحددت الشعره التي قسمت
ظهرا لاتفاق الايطالي
اربعه مصادر مطلعه على المفاوضات اكدت ان
نزاعهما اخرج السودان عن المسار
الديمقراطي مرتين حيث تصاعد التوتر سريعا
مع بدء المحادثات ورفضهما الترحيب ببعضهما
او تبادل اي كلمات اعداء ترسخ عندما لم
يتمكن القائدان من ايجاد ارضيه مشتركه
بشان التسلسل القيادي العسكري لاعاده
تنصيب حكومه مدنيه ومن هنا كرت سبحه
الخلافات وانحرف السودان عن مسار انتقاله
الديمقراطي
فالبرهان يريد ان يكون الشخصيه العسكريه
العليا والوحيده التي تقدم تقاريرها
مباشره الى الحكومه المدنيه وكذلك احمدتي
يسعى الى ان تكون له قناه لا تمر عبر قائد
الجيش ولم يتفقا على اليه تقاسم السلطه
بين الجنرلين والتي من شانها ان تمنح كلا
منهما حقا نقضي على القرارات
اما ارسال قوه الدعم السريع الى القاعده
الجويه والى الخرطوم كان فارقا واستفزازا
صريحا بالنسبه للجيش السوداني ومعه نسفت
امال ايجاد حل عبر الحوار خاصه وان حجم
الهوه بينهما يؤكد اللافقه من اصلها بين
الجانبين الذين جعل السودان رهينه
لخلافاتهما بحسب الصحيفه ما يجعل اقناع
الرجلين بوقف القتال بعيد المنال الا مع
اعلان احدهما النصر ببساطه وصل الى نقطه
لا عوده في تلك العلاقه اسراء الصغير
العربيه
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو الصحفي السوداني
احمد القرشي استاذ احمد اهلا وسهلا فيك
معي في هذه التغطيه جزء من ما تحدث به
البرهان للعربيه قبل قليل في مقابلته هو
يعني يتعلق بهذا التقرير الذي شاهدناه قبل
قليل اولا كيف تعلق على ما جاء في هذه
المقابله وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بعلاقته مع
حماتي طمانينه يعني انا شعرت بانه الشعب
السوداني
الثقل اعطال الجيش
والثقل يعني تولدت من هذا الشعب العظيم
لهذا الجيش الابي اليوم البرهان اكد تماسك
هذا الجيش واكد انه ذاهب يعني في انه ينهي
الازمه الحاليه بالطرق
انجع والاسلم في الظروف المعقده التي
نعيشها من ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه احنا
بنتحدث عن يعني دائما الذاكره في هذه
الظروف والمصالح تسقط يعني انا ما بتحدث
انا بتحدث كمعلومات انه انا اليوم عندما
اتحدث عن حماتي فلابد ان يرجع الناس الى
التاريخ القريب لا يمكن ان تسقط او تسقط
من ذاكره مش هو تاريخ شخص
يعني ضبابي ملفوف بالغاز والسريه لا تاريخ
واضح معروف انه جماعه مسلحه هم
رعاه الصنتيجار دائما بيحمل السلاح
مواشي ومتجاراتهم وكذا جاءت حكومه البشير
اللي هي حكومه اخوانيه وانا بركز على هذا
الشيء اليوم نحن نتكلم عن انه الفلول وكذا
حكومه اخوانيه جاءت بهذا الرجل جاءت به
لماذا انا بالمناسبه حملتي صديق واخوه عبد
الرحيم صديق واهله اصدقائي بالنسبه له لكن
عندما نتكلم عن مصير بلد ونتكلم عن يعني
لحظات فارقه زي ما قلنا في
تشابتر هيد مفترق الطرق ايوه هذا هذا
مفترق يعني الان
كل العلاقات والصداقات يعني
جانبا فانت بتتحدث عن شخص تم تجنيده من
البشير حتى وانه يهزم
صديق قديم من نفس القبيله
تمرد على البشير كان يساعد البشير في
ماده التحركات في دارفور عندما حاول موسى
هلال الزعيم القبلي اللي هو قريبتي انه
ينتفض على البشير او انه يكون عنده راي
مخالف جاء بحميدتي وباسرته وشكلوا ماليزيا
مسلحه مجموعه مسلحه قاتلت موسى هلال
واصبحت هي تتسيد المشهد وهي اداء ضيعه في
يد
عمر البشير حتى يعني قبل يوم من
ذهاب عمر البشير هم كانوا مترددين جدا جدا
في الوقوف مع الناس في الثاني عشر من
ديسمبر لذلك اليوم عندما نتكلم عن حلمتي
يجب انه ما نصل شيئا ويجب
بحجم مهمه جدا جدا ولصدق وللتاريخ انه
حميدتي اللي يعني اللي كبروا البشير
واعطاه كل هذه المميزات الاقتصاديه حميدت
عندما جاء يعني نحن كمان لابد ان نسال
انفسنا ولابد ان نطرح القضايا واضحه امام
الناس عندما جاءت الثوره في الثاني عشر من
ابريل كان لا يملك يعني يملك مال القليل
يعني استثمارات الذهب
مالي كبير اصبح كان يعني تجارته اقل من
500 مليون دولار اليوم
تجارته تحسب بحوالي يعني ده انا مش بحسبها
انا لكن بحسابات موجوده ومحدده بحجم
التجاره والشركات المعاصره 17 مليار دولار
القوه اللي هي الدعم السريع
كانت 25 اليوم اكثر من 160 الف جندي كانت
لا تمتلك معدات واليات
تستطيع ان تطلق الصواريخ وتضاهي الجيش
اليوم لا تضاهي الجيش لكنه لانه لم يرد
ولا انها حلفائه لم يريدون لها ان تكون
مثل الجيش اليوم كلام البرهان لانه دي
مؤسسه لذلك الصدمه اللي حصلت من
المجموعه لو سمينات دعم السريع لانها بجد
من 2017 ما عندها هويه لا معروف تابعه
للجيش لا معروف تابعه للامن ما معروف
تابعه البرنامج نفسه اصدر مرسومه في 2019
بالخروج 17 في 2017 اصدر مرسوما
وضع لها وضعا خاصا مستقلا ايوه لذلك انا
بقول ايش بقول انه هذا ما حدث من عام 2019
لغايه اليوم ايضا لابد ان نسال عنه كيف
تمدد وكيف كبر هذا الرجل الذي هو متهم
جماعه المتهمه بمجزره
القياده الاعتصام واليوم بيتحدث عن انه هو
مع الثوره مع الديمقراطيه
كيف كيف يمكن ان نفهم اليوم
يعني ما يفكر به البرهان تجاه حمدي هوصفها
بانها قوات متمرده على الجيش الجيش وصف
الدعم السريع بانهم عدو وعندما سئل عن
حميتي وهل هو على قائمه الاستهداف قال لا
ليس على قائمه الاستهداف لا نستهدف شخصيات
وقال باننا لا نستهدف شخصيات رسميه هل هذا
تناقض في موقف الجيش تجاه الدعم السريع
برايك ليس بتناقض لكن
كمؤسسه وهو كقائد عام لا يستطيع ان يقول
غير ذلك لكن المعركه مستمره من ناحيه من
ناحيه الثانيه انه نحن بنتحدث عن يعني
الدعم السريع الذي كان قبل سبعه ايام
لم يعد هو الدعم السريع قوه
بتاعته والبنيه العسكريه والماليه بتاعته
انتهت يعني انا ليش بقول طمئن الناس لانه
نحن نعرف ذلك لكن بالامس ساعات ما قدرت
اتصل مع عائلتي موجودين من الوالده ربنا
يطول في عمره يعني تحت يعني تحت
السراير وتحت الدواليب ليش لانه القصف وصل
مناطق قريبه جدا جدا من الاحياء السكنيه
ففي خوف وفي فزع رهيب لكن رغما عن ذلك
اغلب الناس لا يريدون الذهاب الى اي مكان
لسبب بسيط لانه موقنين انه الجيش السوداني
وانا تاني بكرر الجيش السوداني الجيش
السوداني اليوم مره الجيش السوداني اليوم
لما يتكلم البرهان هو القائد العام
القوات المسلحه هذه القوات المسلحه تدرك
يعني هي 1885
1925 وكل يعني
المعارضه اللي جات من ليبيا بدعم ليبي
الانقلابات اللي حدثت دائما كانت هكذا
يعني عندها راسخه في انها تتعامل مع الاخر
وغيره انا اعتقد انه دلوقتي هم امام مهمه
بسيطه انه يعني يتراجعوا عن ما هم في حتى
انه يعني يوجد مخرج كيف هذا المخرج
لا ادري لكن الجيش مؤكد انه حتى الجيش قبل
قليل
لانه لا يمكن لا يمكن الاجابه معليش
الاجابه هي انه نعم بعد بكره او بعد ثلاثه
ايام او بعد اسبوع عندما ماتتحقق يحصل
احباط عام لذلك اقول انه الناس العامه
ونحن من العامه نمتلك المعلومه انه الجيش
ذاهب لكن انت بتتعامل مع ميليشيا
سريعه الحركه عندها قوه عندها اصرار كبير
ان تكون موجوده اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
وجودك معي على كل هذه المعلومات وكل هذه
التفاصيل نتمنى السلامه ان شاء الله
بكل طبعا شكرا جزيلا لك كان معي هنا في
الاستوديو الصحفي السوداني احمد القرشي
شكرا جزيلا
اذا اكد وزير الصحه السوداني هيثم محمد ان
القطاع الطبي يواجه تحديات في امداد
المستشفيات بالوقود مشيرا الى ان مخزن
الامدادات الطبيه الرئيسي تدمر بالكامل
توجد صعوبه في ايصال الامداد الامدادات
المركزيه ما تاثرت كانت هنالك مشكله في
الوقود لها وتم التنسيق مع
وزاره الطاقه على ستار لايصال الامداد
الوقود بالنسبه لهم وطمنوهم في هذا الجانب
للاسف المركز الامدادات الرئيسي مخزن
امدادات الرئيس تي في ولايه جنوب دارفور
في نهايه نتعرض للاهلاك الكامل والحرق
الكامل
ينضم الينا من لندن مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للتنميه والعونه الانساني الصادق محمد
احمد السيده صادق مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه اولا كيف تقيمون الاوضاع
الانسانيه في السودان حتى هذه اللحظه
اليوم ندخل الاسبوع الثاني من هذا
الاحتراف في السودان
حقيقه الوضع الصحي والانساني في السودان
غايه في السوق وفي كل يوم تستمر فيه
المعارك تزداد معاناه المواطنين
هناك صعوبه كبيره في ايصال الان حتى بعض
المساعدات المتوفره داخليا الى
المستشفيات والى كذلك
المتضررين اضف الى ذلك هناك صعوبه كبيره
جدا في الوصول كوادر الكوادر الطبيه الى
المستشفيات المختلفه الوضع
ازداد سوءا من
اليومين السابقين اكثر خلال هذا اليوم حسب
متابعتنا لان هناك كما ذكرت صعوبه في وصول
حتى الكوادر الطبيه معظم المستشفيات حسب
معلوماتنا في الخرطوم تحديدا تحولت الى
كانها مستشفياتها واقسام طوارئ فقط ان
تقوم باعمال الطوارئ
واسعاف المصابين
بمعنى انه حتى المرضى الذين عنوا من
الامراض الاخرى
صعوبه الان صعوبه كبيره جدا في مراجعه
المستشفيات المرضى الفشل الكلوي مرضى
السكر والضغط والعمليات الجراحيه تكاد
تكون متوقفه بالكامل الان في معظم
مستشفيات
الخرطومه والسودان كذلك ما الذي يعود وصول
مساعداتكم الى السودان السيد الصادق
طبعا الوضع الامني الوضع الامني الصعب
الان لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال التحدث
عن ايصال المساعدات الى اي مكان سواء كان
الى المحتاجين
بمواد بمواد الغذائيه والمواد التموينيه
او الى المستشفيات الكارثه البيئيه متوقعه
ايضا بانتشار عدد كبير جدا من الجثث في
شوارع الخرطوم الان هذه عمليه الان تقلق
المنظمات العامله في المجال الانساني
بصوره كبيره بالرغم من ان حسب تواصلنا مع
الجهات المعنيه في السودان هناك اتم انشاء
غرف طوارئ من اجل انشال الجثث من الشوارع
لمنع تدهور الوضع الصحي وانتشار الاوبئه
وايضا هم يجدون صعوبه في ايصال بعض المواد
الضروريه للمستشفيات حسب ما هي متوفره
لانه حسب افادتهم يتم استهداف سيارات
الاسعاف من قبل من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
تحت يظنون انها تتبع الى الجيش هذه حسب
قائدتهم وبالتالي يتم الاعتداء عليها
واستهدافها بصوره مباشره
ما الذي ينقص السودان فيما يخص الادويه
الكوادر الصحيه ايضا هل تم التواصل معكم
مباشره من داخل السودان سواء كان من
الكوادر الطبيه او حتى ايضا مناشدات شخصيه
كثير من المناسبات الشخصيه وكثيره
والمشاهدات ايضا من
قبل المروعيه العامله في السودان وذلك
بضروره ان يتم
التواصل مع الجهات الرسميه او الضغط عليها
عن طريق المجتمع الدولي من اجل الطرد
بحدنا على الاقل تتيح
للمنظمات في صار المساعدات اليها هناك
كبير جدا في الادويه
الضروريه المستشفيات هناك كبير حاد جدا
واكاد يكون الوقت تقريبا سينفذ اذا لم يتم
الوصول الى حل عادل حسب افادات القوات
المسلحه ان هناك فتره متوقعه ان يتم فيها
حسم المعارك ونحن نطلع الى هذه
الفتره التي تم
تحديدها بيومين او ثلاثه ايام على الاكثر
حسب افاداتهم
يعني انتم فقط تنتظرون تطبيق الهدنه
الانسانيه حتى تستطيعون ايصال هذه
المساعدات الى داخل الخرطوم مباشره يعني
هي المنطقه التي تعاني بشكل كبير
حقيقه حتى موضوع هذا امر انا لا اعتقد انه
سيحوز على ثقه المنظمات
الطوعيه من الخارج للدخول الى السودان لان
هناك اعتداء تبنى على منظمات على برنامج
الغذاء العالمي ثم ثلاث الموظفين قبل ايام
هناك احتلال كبير جدا على مقر المنظمات
العامله هناك الهلال الاحمر السوداني نفسه
تم نهب ثمانيه سيارات منهم من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع حسب الافاداتهم انه تم
استخدامها لايقافه او التعامل مع الجرحى
السريع وتم ازاله من المنظمات الطبيعيه
فلا اعتقد ان الهدنه وحدها كافيه لابد ان
يكون هناك ادله واضحه على استجباب الامن
وسلامه
العاملين في المجال الانساني حتى
تقوم المنظمات المختلفه في استئناف عملها
في السودان علقت كثير من المنظمات منها
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ولا حدود وكذلك
بقيه المنظمات الطبيعيه
ايضا التابع الامم المتحده اعتقد انه تم
قتل احد موظفيها خلال اليوم
على طبيعه نشاط المنظمات في الفتره
المقبله ولا اتوقع ان يتم استهلاك عملها
بصوره كامله اذا لم يتكون هناك كامل للامن
على الارض وبالتالي كل المنظمات المنظمات
الاغاثيه المنظمات الدوليه الانسانيه ايضا
في السودان علقت عملها لن يعني
تعيد العمل الى السودان هذه الوكالات الا
بعد استتباب الاوضاع الامنيه هل هذا ما
افهمه السيد الصادق هذا هذا صحيح بصوره
كبيره
على على على الشعب السوداني الذي لا حول
ولا قوه ولا علاقه له بما يجري
وحتى ربما الجاليات المختلفه سواء المتحده
بريطانيا بعض الدول الاخرى واظن ان هذا
لوحده دليل كافي على ان هناك عدم ثقه في
ان الوضع يعني على الارض امن
كنت اسال بان الشعب السوداني لا علاقه له
اليوم بما يجري وهو المتضرر الاكبر مما
يحدث فما هي البدائل بالنسبه لي
السودانيين خصوصا من يسكنون داخل الخرطوم
متضررين على المستوى الصحي الانسان في
المقام الاول والصحي الغذائي على مستوى
حتى ايضا المياه اليوم المياه تباع مثلا
في السودان مياه غير الصالحه للشرب باسعار
فلكيه اغلى بكثير وباضعاف اسعار
المياه الشرب الصحيه سيد الصادق
للاسف للاسف هذه هي الحقيقه الوضع الوضع
بصوره عامه كارثي وضع وضع سيء جدا انا
يعني
انقل لديك اخبار ان هناك بعض الاسر وبعض
الافراد حتى عالقون من بدايه اليوم الاول
في مناطق الخرطوم في بعض المناطق ولم لم
يتم اياهم حتى الان يعيشون ظروف سيئه جدا
انقطاع الكهرباء عدم وجود يكاد يكون بعضهم
يعني يومين او ثلاثه ايام لم يتناول يعني
الا القليل من الغذاء والماء والان وضعهم
كارثي يعني يمكن ان تقول ان هناك بعض
الاسر ربما سيموتون من الجوع من الخوف
الوضع سيء الوضع سيء عن البدائل الاخرى
بالنسبه للمواطنين الذين يعتبروا محظوظين
انهم يعني تم ادلاهم من المناطق العمليات
واصبحت منافق امنه سواء كانت في مناطق
السودان او الى تملاهم الى ق بعيده من
الخرطوم الى حد ما هناك على الاقل
يتعاملون مع الوضع بصوره افضل يكاد يكون
متوفر لهم بعض الخضروات هناك الزراعه يعني
في تلك المناطق
يتعاملون يعني بصوره افضل ولكن الوضع
الكارسي في الخرطوم حقيقه معظم اجزاء
الخرطوم سواء كانت الاحياء الطرفيه او
وسطه مناطق العمليات هي الاكثر التي يتم
فيها العمليات العسكريه بين القوات
المسلحه وغير الدعم السريع هم المتضررون
بصوره اكبر ونامل ان يكون هناك
سيطره القوات المسلحه على بعض المناطق حتى
يتم لان انا اعتقد القوات المسلحه حريصه
الى حد كبير على اجلاء المواطنين وعلى
سلامتهم اكثر من قوات الدعم السريع نعتقد
ذلك اشكرك جزيل الشكر على انضمامك الينا
من لندن مدير الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه
والعوني الانساني الصادق محمد احمد جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات